[Music]
so what do you guys know about the
cleveland browns it's a football team
they are they always suck didn't even
give us a chance i don't think i don't
think you will know so do they always
suck did their quarterback get in
trouble no how do you always suck in
football like you never win a game from
what i know yeah it was like them and
the lions right like they're like the
practice game the practice team that
everyone beats up for like the generals
or the generals i remember one draft
like you got like this quarterback and
you're supposed to like manziel right or
something and he's supposed to be good
but they say
uh how does that happen it's like even
more diggers yeah it was like the
raiders when they got jamarcus russell
marcus russell has an interesting story
wait did the browns pick up deshaun
watson did bronze picked up john watson
gave 230 million dollars guaranteed
after knowing that he had all of these
it was like 23 women 22 women at the
time i think were suing him um based on
saying that he was um trying to get
massages from them and then he would
start to do lewd sexual activity with
them or try to uh solicit them to do
like jacob
and like
so then the
he was my brothel friend
so so then this was this was all looked
at by a grand jury just recently like
just like a month and a half ago and
they cleared desean and said
no no no criminal charges will be filed
right that doesn't mean that you can't
have a personal yeah um lawsuit with him
right like like civil lawsuit with him
but but that means that he won't have
any criminal whoa well so then the
browns go guess what dude deshawn was so
good because he was really good on the
on the texans which is a dog [ __ ] team
as well that was the last team he was on
i forgot about it and they cut him right
trash team trash city
trash ownership everything awful where
wait where's their city houston texas oh
what
a terrible city horrible city everything
but horrible legacy no legacy at all
houston texas suck ass right but him and
jj watt right him and jj watt complete
dog [ __ ] of a person i'm kidding he's
he's apparently agreed he's like a nice
guy but he's in he's in the cardinals
now so it doesn't matter but no so he um
was playing so well for them but then he
took a year off because basically he
felt like the organization wasn't
supporting him at all like he was too
good for the organization so he was
going to sit up right so then all these
lawsuits start coming out and then all
this momentum builds right so now he
gets cleared and it looks like it's all
good to go the browns go guess what we
want you to buy our [ __ ] quarterback
we're gonna give you 230 million dollars
guaranteed no matter what the [ __ ]
happens and that's pretty rare right oh
bro it's the highest ever
is that a payout in one year five years
oh but but if and but usually it's not
guaranteed but even if it gets injured
it's 500 something million the contract
right but the but the guaranteed money
is what matters is there any athlete
that gets paid
that much the nfl i think in the end not
in the nfl but nba nba yeah i guess
steph curry and then mlb too it's like
[ __ ] wild tom brady just got a a
500 million contract to do um
yeah fox sports for like 10 years yeah
well as a commentator yeah or 350
million no but i mean like as a as a
athlete like in a team no no athletes at
the time rarely make the same money yeah
right and then read most recently
yeah i don't i think it was mahomes
but i think it's that right they get
these contracts but that doesn't mean
necessarily you're getting all that
money because it's not guaranteed
especially in nfl it's a little flighty
because if you get injured or something
you're out they don't continue to team
can just cut you or they can um yeah
they can just say like well we're gonna
say but baseball contracts are legit
though i heard they pay out for a long
time and then the injuries are low and
[ __ ] and so the nfl pa has always had an
issue nfl players association has always
had an issue because the nfl has so much
power that the nfl pa only until the
really last decade have they been able
to encroach on some of that power to get
more money for the players because the
players are really ridiculously
underpaid for all the revenue that the
nfl got but so deshawn
just got 230 million dollars guaranteed
right but he might not even play a
[ __ ] game for the brown what
because there's a brand new lawsuit that
came out so independent of the grand
jury oh my god the new lawsuit just came
out like last week like nine days ago
and this massage therapist
she was watching this hbo special that
they did on like the entire deshawn case
and how deshawn was being defiant about
it and not like necessarily apologetic
towards the women he was being like very
much like
i am a classy man i did nothing wrong
and [ __ ] and so she was like you know
what [ __ ] you because i know what you
did to me
and she says that he
during a massage like at the end of it
he wanted her to jerk him off and she
she wouldn't do it and then he basically
jerked off on her whoa you just [ __ ]
just
she took a little little selfie no we
don't know we don't know damn so so we
don't know what the extent of it is but
but this is a really troubling new
allegation for him and his team because
now it's back to the criminal case right
so the criminal case that everyone the
bronze thought was going to go away it's
not double jeopardy because it's a new
it's a new case new new woman came
forward who wasn't part of the original
case holy [ __ ] so puts everything into
questions all question marks boom
explode all over the [ __ ] but no
matter what he gets the 230 million well
that depends because there is there is a
clause in the contract that it involves
wrongdoing that could maybe work out in
his
against his right against the money yeah
but but the browns look [ __ ] is the
whole thing yeah because they they're
the curse and all that money yeah well
they just they just also [ __ ] over
baker mayfield yeah who was their
quarterback who actually won them the
first playoff game like in but they're
like we rather have this guy yeah
exactly and so they just came out snaked
him they actually were they actually
were um
in the discussion for a couple of
players so matt ryan colts just got matt
ryan because
the falcons were like yo we um we want
to be in on the desean watson and
sweepstakes because a lot of people
wanted a lot of uh teams wanted to get
deshawn watson because he was a free
agent right because the charges were
dropped and now you know the nfl texas
let him go the kick they kept themselves
had to cut him well they were trading
him but they were only going to trade
him because he had a he had a basically
the first right to to decide where he
wanted to go so so he could just say
like i don't want to be on these teams
so then the texans met with only teams
that were that were pre-approved
basically with certain packages that
they were offering the texans for picks
and then cash for deshaun
yeah so yeah so this is crazy because
this woman um
basically holds his entire future in the
balance that's why you just got to go to
[ __ ] dudes to get rubbed down
honestly no really like one of my
favorites
one of my homies who's a massage
therapist does like some football guys
and they get guys to do it for that
reason so that that can't happen at all
so they get happy endings from the dudes
well you never know
because guys won't talk
it's bullies
are that like no matter what like
there's nothing there's no funny
business no risk of like a girl like
getting too horny yeah i will say though
when guys you know when you go to the
massage parlor then it's not like a
chicken it's a dude a part of you is
like oh man it's a dude and the next
part of you is like oh man this might be
real strong and you're down for it
kind of interesting
that happened to me because i was like
i'm gonna request a lady because i just
don't know you know this guy might be
too horny and [ __ ] he might come on at
me because i'm
there there was no ladies and then he
was like i don't know he reminded me of
bart's dad he was like come on come on
come on i was like all right [ __ ] it
let's do this [ __ ] and i sat down and as
soon as i sat down he just started going
like this and i started melting like oh
[ __ ] this guy is good
he started doing this [ __ ] and i was
like yup man you know what though his
blunt hands just felt way better than a
sharp woman's hand really
did he start reaching for your inner
thighs and start tapping it to see if
you want him is that is that the same
thing that happened
no but he did a credit card and i went
whoo
is that how you paid so yeah the browns
just the browns just alienated baker
mayfield who was the starting
quarterback who got them to win a
playoff game because they were so horny
for deshawn yeah right and then now
deshawn might not play baker doesn't
want to play one more down for them
he actually put out an ad in a newspaper
saying thank you to the browns fans and
basically like i'll never play for the
team again but thank you guys so [ __ ]
much and [ __ ] and i'm sure people want
him too right is he still part of the
fans do what's up that guy is still on
the team he's still on the team he
hasn't been cut by the team will they
get fined if he doesn't play well no
they're waiting he got benched they're
waiting for a trade package yeah he's
he's the second string quarterback on
the team now but they're waiting for
they're hoping to get a trade package
for him but nobody [ __ ] really wants
him how crazy that because they were
waiting for the draft and then now the
draft's over they all kind of got
settled in the quarterback situation so
now maybe he'll be a backup somewhere
but then the browns just basically had
to say like hey we're about to do
training camp training camp something
right now as we talk right they don't
have a quarterback they don't have a
quarterback well they have desean still
throwing the ball in training camp but
they don't know that he'll actually be
able to take the field for a regular
season because the nfl has the right
the roger goodell the the the guy in
charge right he has the right to just
say like hey he's suspended for this for
the full season and then the browns
could be fun so with no quarterback here
and they just have to pay out all that
money let's pay all that money but what
they actually structured his contract
anticipating suspensions so he actually
gets paid very very little for the first
couple of games in order to to backload
his contract wow so that they were like
i said they were anticipating this they
backload his contract so if he does get
suspended without pay
he's not getting paid those games anyway
it was very minimal and he's such a
really good he's such a good quarterback
he was a good quarterback yeah he
actually really was this is the perfect
plot for water boy too
[Laughter]
where's adam sadler when we need him he
just came out of the new movie it's
pretty good too you mean the one with
chris rock hustle yeah hustle he's a
coach for the uh sixers sixers yeah
pretty good he's good yeah but he's
another one too and you're looking
everywhere like he's getting old is he
doing the like i show uh
[Laughter]
like a third of his movies he did that
the same voice yeah yeah yeah his mr
deeds one
yeah and a little nicky and mr deeds
yeah little nicky was so good look it's
great movie the only time i ever hear
about the cleveland browns is when
people use that uh figure of speech to
say they're gonna go take a [ __ ] yeah
i'm going to take a clean one
when they go where are you going i'm
taking the cleveland browns to the super
bowl
that's so good have you ever seen the
dog pound photo from cleveland the
cleveland browns fans no this is worth
it so um this is kind of a joke about
really ohio in general um so they're
they finally put up the money to get us
good start players so hope that they can
win and then they still suck because
they're not gonna even get them so
they're gonna still keep blue curse
continues but there was a game where
like like so the cleveland browns have
this thing where they called themselves
it's like this is the dog power like our
stadium is the dog pound like we're you
know we're the [ __ ] dogs or whatever
right and
um say it so they had a banner right and
you have to you have to wonder when
you're when you see something like this
they had a banner like that was in three
sections and it was like they're
supposed to sell what spell out well
this is the dog pound but then like the
fans i don't think knew how to read or
they were too drunk and so that's that's
what turned into all [ __ ] odds
and that's the epitome of everything
that happens in cleveland
right there